who's making all that noise up there hey
everybody here we are back again it's
Sunday hopefully yeah oh you're doing it
again
every single time every single time all
right I just said before before I hit
the button I'm just gonna sighs like are
you ready like terms of [ __ ] volume up
if you hear like little noises in the
background that's uh that's pollution
you know she's back there tearing
something up I don't know what I see
people showing up Hey these nests that
sidequest
got six of them online right now yeah I
got 11 yeah 11 okay yeah they're all
starting to filter in hey what's up you
guys today we're gonna be talking about
the new unsolved mysteries yeah on
Netflix what I didn't realize because
they put six episodes of it up well
they're gonna have six more they're just
gonna I don't think they're gonna put
them up until September maybe or like
later on in the year so they actually
are gonna have like a 12 okay episode
series there's gonna release it into bad
but they're releasing it in two batches
apparently that's that's what I heard
yeah all right so first off you know
when if you grew up on all unsolved
mysteries you're gonna remember that
damn theme song it's that's an iconic
and it's got that same theme song yeah
it's it is a slightly different take on
it it doesn't seem quite as intense it
seems a little bit chilled out but it is
that theme song yeah
and they didn't and we were wondering
who the [ __ ] are they gonna replace
Robert Stack with man everybody's
showing up look at everybody so I was
kind of stressing about it was like men
who are they gonna replace Robert Stack
with well guess what they didn't replace
him with anybody yeah Robert stacks in
it but only in the [ __ ] opening scene
you see a pitcher like a silhouette of
robber stacks face and then there's no
host at all and every enactment no
reenactment which I was reading a
interview with the producers of the show
and this actually has one of the same
producers as stranger things
interestingly and they got like the
people that were behind the original on
saw mr. 9 1987 so they're behind it as
well
and they said you know we had a like a
huge discussion about if we were gonna
have a host or not and then they said
pretty much the same thing they said
there's no way that anyone could fill
Robert Stack shoes he's so iconic and so
you know related to the show that we
didn't want to you know kind of like you
know they didn't want to have to like
replace him because they thought it
would just be better to kind of bring
things more up into like a contempt more
contemporary like sure crime kind of
series and also they kind of got rid of
the they do like a little bit of
reenactment because remember I think a
lot of people really likes the
reenactments like from the original show
just because some of them were kind of
cheesy yeah but um I think they decided
they just do them kind of like um you
know not so much of reenactment is like
you know they're saying something
happening but they'll just show like
just should have seen like a scene but
they're you know know what's talking or
anything like that I think was kind of
the better way to do it out of the six
of them that they should that they have
up there now five were kind of like true
crime missing-person type deal and then
one of them to make the sixth one is a
UFO case and I liked that one I liked
the UFO case it was very interesting
yeah it was a crazy story what yeah it
was a crazy I think maybe it happened
it's hard to tell it wasn't quite as
exciting as the open case that they did
back in the day that was a really good
episode some of the flying triangle
wants you know they're really good but
so far I'm pleased with what they did
with it I think not having a Robert
Stack or a host in it I think was the
right way to go I think
getting rid of the older format with the
reenactments I think that was also the
right way to go and just the edit I
think is a lot more modern you see that
the old original onyx solve mysteries a
lot of that was filler a lot of em is
filler and it repeated itself kinda yeah
I mean like for breaks and [ __ ] like
that you know for commercial breaks or
they backtrack has show something again
sometimes some of some of the episodes
that did feel like they were kind of
trying to stretch it out because there
wasn't very much
material in it and so far not that's not
really the case with this ones there's a
lot of meat and potatoes to these cases
well it's interesting too because I feel
like the original series they usually
had at least two cases like on each
episode because episodes were like you
know 48 minutes or whatever they were
like an hour
Herschel's and they would do between
like 2 & 4 cases like on each show so
they didn't really have a lot of time to
go that in-depth on each case yeah so
it's interesting that they did kind of
like repeat things I'm like you said
that happened a lot with all TV shows
like back in the day people watch them
on broadcast TV it's like they would
have derailment remind you like when you
get back into commercials they'd like
remind you I guess it was people that
were tuning in like in the middle of it
like that you know we're flipping
through it was just a format of the
times - yeah like I said all this says
we're kind of yeah and people kind of
were trained to watch TV that way but if
you go back and watch them on YouTube
because some of those cases are up there
they think it took a lot of them down
but they used to be up there you'd watch
those watch those old episodes they were
kind of harder to watch they're kind of
hard to watch by today's standards yeah
and he entered a little bit I kind of
you know what I mean it's just very it
was like a real strong formula behind
him yeah and we get kind of annoying you
know I think what ended up happening
with unsolved mysteries is so many
people were posting them like and you
know stepping on the copyright so I
think what initially I'm not sure but I
think what they ended up doing was just
opening their own YouTube channel the
official like unsung mysteries so they
could put and they have like X amount of
you know episodes up there they might
they might have them I think they have
some of them want to be as well bees
nest her and just say that uh may he
wish that they'd bring back on [ __ ]
that home in search of C that would be
cool to you now the thing about and I
like I said I was reading an interview
with the producers of unsolved mysteries
and they were saying that you know they
definitely wanted to do some of the more
like you know quote-unquote paranormal
stuff because that was kind of such a
big you know aspect of the original show
but they said some of this stuff that
they used to have on the original show
like you know especially like lost loves
or people looking for like their lost
relatives and stuff they're like we keep
you know in this day and age like where
everybody is social media and everything
yeah you know you can't really do that
anymore because it's so much easier you
know she should go through ancestry.com
or you know find them on Facebook or
some like that if they have services
they can come all right it's much easier
to find people nowadays you don't really
like need a TV show to do it so it does
seem like they're concentrating more on
mysterious disappearances mysterious
murders and they did do one UFO case and
I kind of like so I do like that they
just focus on one case per episode which
I guess some people could argue makes it
like more of a generic true crime
documentary style show you know cuz
Dateline does the same thing and you
know all that other kind of stuff and
maybe it's not as distinctive but I
don't know like I said I don't know
they'll be pretty good case yeah they
were really good cases and I think they
really um yeah I think I think it was
really good that they had the time to go
in depth and like all this different
stuff and yeah yeah I know well it's
Florida yeah summer in Florida it
happens pretty much every day but yeah
so we could talk a little bit about some
of the cases and the the cool thing
about this too is that they have the
website you know unsolved comm which
kind of that was the whole point of the
show from the very beginning was like to
get people to like help them like solve
the mysteries and stuff and even like
the original run of the show I think
they ended up solving like two hundred
and sixty cases that they presented on
their which is actually pretty good
before we go on of the cases let me say
hi to everybody who's here by 21 he's
got business in here SciQuest here was
that it is there he's getting ready to
go out and do some [ __ ] Tami Melissa's
back Debra's back Beth oh and also I
wanted to I wanted to give another thank
you to Logan again I thanked him on the
show last night too for sending me a
PayPal donation he sent me another
PayPal donation today this morning so
thank you very much Logan I wanted to
make sure that I got that in there
Oracle's in I know I was kind of
laughing oh come on Lana's him he's back
from our commercial break and let us
remind you of what we talked about two
minutes ago yeah exactly I'm just kind
of like they still do it sometimes
because we've been watching like smooth
Gordon Ramsay shows like 24 hours a
hollaback and I'm
actually men on to be where they don't
have like a [ __ ] set on commercials it's
like they just have one every now and
then but I've noticed that they still do
that with like these TV shows because
you know it'll be like you know Gordon
will be yelling at somebody and then
it'll be like oh here's where a
commercial break would have gone and
then you come back and they just repeat
the same thing over again I'm like we
were all just here man
Connor Fox lawns and he's brought the
whole Jaguar army with him fresh GJ and
concen and he's in classic TJ he's in
the 1970s Tijuana he's not in modern
Tijuana you got that time traveler okay
and he said child Island man needs an
episode we can we need to do that
there's so much that though I think
child Island man well I think Netflix
just came out that I am watched it yet I
think they just came out with a
documentary about it it's gonna be hard
to compete with some of those high
quality shows about the man that had the
island and the children and his
girlfriend who just got arrested a child
Island woman I don't want to name them
because it might [ __ ] up the algorithms
and they come if I could pull the show
CIA jumps through my window ya know
though I tell you what man Weinstein
wise Weinstein what am I gonna call
Weinstein I'm gonna say a naughty movie
man that's not my call naughty movie man
he was in prison but they let him out
because of the kovat so he got out
that's weird huh yeah you can rape some
people but because you're a naughty
movie man and they don't want you to get
sick they'll let you out of jail I don't
one thing I put him back in well I would
hope so why don't they just let him get
köppen because he's a naughty movie man
with a bunch of money he's one of his
you know something he's childish child
Island's man's friend yeah so that's you
know they they know too much they got
power yeah so all right so like I said
I'm not sure when the when the remaining
six
besides of unsolved mysteries you're
gonna go up but the six that they have
up there in case you guys haven't seen
them now the first one this one to me
like they were all interesting stories
this one to me seemed the most
interesting because it just had like the
weirdest little details and I love like
yeah I don't love it because it's tragic
but it's like I'm really interested in
cases have like these weird little
details so the first one was just called
mystery on on the rooftop and now it's
about it was about this guy named Ray
Rivera who yeah hold on this is the guy
that you were just posted about you know
you were asking us about unsolved
mysteries this she's talking about that
case Rivera his name is Rivera right
yeah Ray Rivera raver very yeah he was
found dead like he jumped off a building
but it doesn't it looks awful strange
and we he hit the roof he went through
the roof and ended up inside the [ __ ]
building it was awesome right dude it
was the Belvedere Hotel the historic
Belvedere Hotel which I believe is kind
of minions now and offices but they
showed it it's in Baltimore and um yeah
it's their kind of operating under the
assumption assumption I think his death
they they ruled it like undetermined I
think it was an accident well I don't
know it's it just seems like I don't
know just there are so many weird
details about like what the [ __ ] was he
doing up there
it's like it seemed like there was
somebody like his wife was out of town
or at work or something like that and
apparently they had a houseguest staying
there the house guest heard ray Rivera
get a phone call and then he kind of
he'd like rushed out of the house like
you know it you know like he was in a
hurry and then they didn't know where he
was for awhile and then they found his
car in the parking lot of of the
Belvedere or like near there like cuz I
guess he worked for a company that was
near there and then they found this hole
in the roof and they go in the room
which I think it was like a conference
room or something like that and they
found him all like [ __ ] broken and
dead in there yeah he'd been there for
about a week or so huh yeah and you've
been there a while they didn't know
where he was so it's like so they're
sitting there thinking well one it
seemed really weird like there was three
possible places that he could have
jumped from or been pushed or whatever
and I'm not really sure why he would
have gone up there I think the police
were kind of operating under the
assumption that it was a suicide but I
don't know it just seemed like a really
weird thing for him to be doing and
there was like all these little details
like you know like I said he had smashed
through the roof it was like a hole in
the roof and that's what alerted them to
like where the body was but he had like
hit the shoes that he'd had on them were
like next to the hole and his phone was
next to the hole like nothing was broken
like his glasses weren't broken which he
would think that they would be if he
fell back and no one saw him either no
one saw him come in the building nobody
saw him fallen past the window nobody
saw anything which I thought was also
very weird your terminal velocity when
you fall you build up enough speed you
end up traveling about 110 miles an hour
as fast but that's not all that fast
the human body's kind of mushy you have
time up if you had the phone in your
back pocket and your glasses on your
back pocket or in your front pocket and
you hit on your back or something like
that chances are your body could protect
the phone and the glasses
maybe on the it's just seemed weird
though that it was all like they were
just outside the hole well when he hit
he probably bad messages will pop and it
popped out maybe from the impact but it
wait physics all worked he was going
down and then the glasses and the the
phone were going up and it just kind of
took it wasn't it wasn't a real violent
trip for the glasses in the phone I
didn't weigh much that's true I think
that's what it was but that I mean to me
that wasn't the weirdest thing well the
weirdest thing to me was you know who
the [ __ ] called him they weren't
actually sure who it was they knew that
it came from his workplace but they
didn't know whose phone it was because
it went through the UM through the what
you call it switchboard yeah so there
was another weird thing too that they
found this little piece of paper like
taped to the back of his computer and it
was this really weird like it had all
this Freemason [ __ ] on it and like [ __ ]
about Stanley Kubrick and all this other
stuff now I don't like that took details
to me seems really weird although I will
say that he was a screenwriter so I mean
if I died unexpectedly and people
started going
like my notes like that there be all
kind of weird [ __ ] and they like people
that you know like ideas for stories or
like for games or something like that
so it might have just been that it does
seem really weird that it was taped to
the back of his computer like it is
thinking but wasn't a suicide note or
nothing like that it was just this weird
rambling there's a lot of weird stuff
and it we prize [ __ ] this for that cuz I
don't think everybody's seen it yeah and
you want to give him a chance to watch
it but it is good I I don't think it was
murder
although it is weird the one guy that he
worked with won't talk to anybody that
does seem weird I'm not saying I think
he was murdered I'm just saying I think
I think it was some kind of an accident
there's just like a lot of really weird
details I got on a Ledge for some reason
I think he was out on that big ledge man
like I said why was he what was he doing
out there I don't know it's just see
that's to me the weirdest thing he was
cycling that made sense at the time I
guess um maybe he was trying to look
into somebody's window when she went out
on the ledge to look in through the
windows I don't need to look at anybody
yeah [ __ ] me this is a tall building
and it's just like I don't know it was
creeping me out he or he went out let's
go get somethin so that's blowin or
something blew out or something yeah it
just seems very it wasn't suicide I
don't think he had a reason to kill
himself he didn't seem to I mean he had
just married he didn't like no one said
he was upset or like stressed out about
anything I don't know it just seemed
really odd it was like it was almost
like not quite as weird but it was
almost like the [ __ ] that ELISA Lam
[ __ ] where they found her like up on the
roof and the [ __ ] yeah in the water
tank it was it was a little bit like
that not quite as weird yeah I saw has
she was acted no man that she was on she
was [ __ ] whacked out on drugs
it probably talked about I wish I had a
psychic break now it's called [ __ ] LSD
real powerful LSD and I think she jumped
down in there to get to swim or
something and then once she got in there
she realized there was no way out no way
but back out of that down yeah water
tower yeah because you know when people
are [ __ ] up on things you know even
alcohol or various other drug so
sometimes stupid things seem like a good
time and then later on when you're sober
yeah let's shut it down there was it she
went down there on her own
but yeah
so and so I don't know but that that one
to me like was I think that was the most
interesting just because there were so
many weird little details and plus I'm
like really really scared of heights and
so all the all the shots of like the
Belvedere who I was like stressing me
out was you know it scare me so the
second one is called 13 minutes and that
was one where it was a woman named
Patrice black right and she was she
worked at a salon and she was apparently
she had a client and you know she cut
their hair or whatever and then they
left and then in a 13 minute window she
went missing and like nobody saw
anything particularly weird except in
her car was parked in the front of the
place instead of on the side where she
usually parked it cuz everybody knew
like her in this town and everything cuz
she was kind of a well-known hair slit
you know she ran out well-known hair
salon so she just disappeared and then
they found her body like six days later
something like that like they actually
maybe it was a longer time than that but
yeah they eventually did find her body
like six miles away from the salon and
they're not entirely sure like it didn't
seem like like nothing was disturbed in
the salon like the cash register was
open and I think the cash was gone but
her purse was still there and like all
of her other [ __ ] was still there so it
seemed like somebody just walked in and
like forced her out somehow but they
can't figure out like who it was and can
I just say that the one of the people
that they talk to a lot on this
particular episode was hurt was
Patrice's son because he was a kid like
I think he was in junior high or high
school when his mom disappeared and his
name is pistol black I was like is that
like the coolest [ __ ] name an effort
I was like man I wish that was my name
yeah but that one goes through there's
like several guys that could have done
serial killers yeah it could have done
it or it might have been someone got
eliminated yeah so they did kind of go
into that so that was a very standard it
was just very weird because it was like
the middle of the day was like lunchtime
or something right and there was like a
really short window for it to have
happened so I don't know if it was just
some random person that drove by or if
someone that knew her or something like
that it was just really really weird
that happened in coming jour
I think in 2004 20 months later her body
wasn't found for 20 months so yes you
got her yes so she'd been out there for
a really long time now the third episode
this was actually the only case that I
had heard of prior to seeing it on this
show it's called house of terror and
that's the one about count ligament
Leona's is that who's it's a French if
it was a French family and the whole
family including their dogs disappeared
and then somebody sent letters to like
their friends and families saying that
they were going undercover to work in
the United States for the DEA or
something but then like the cops kept
going to their house because the
family's like that sounds like [ __ ]
that doesn't sound like something they
would do it was like it was a man and
woman and they were you know they were
quite wealthy um you know they were like
nobility or whatever and they had four
kids who were mostly grown I think there
was one that was kind of a teenager but
so the cops kept going and they didn't
find anything and they didn't find
anything and then finally like the sixth
time the cops went they're like okay
this is like getting crazy now and then
they found the bodies it was like
underneath the terrace like in all these
[ __ ] even the dogs were down there
but the only dude that was missing was
the dead count Ligon s so they're
operating under the assumption that he
killed his entire family and their dogs
yeah jerk for some reason and then took
off but the mystery being did he kill
them and if he did where the [ __ ] is he
now because they have no idea where this
there's been some guys that done did
that in the past kill their whole family
and disappear yeah and then it turns out
that he loved his family and [ __ ] that
what he lost his job so he couldn't
support him so he killed him that's some
weird I kind of feel like this might be
something like that because he didn't
seem to like the way he killed them like
he wrapped up their bodies very
carefully like he gave them like they
were Catholic so he like put little
religious symbols on there so it's
almost an ancient yeah like it wasn't
out of anger almost it was just this
weird I can no longer support my family
I don't know if that's what it was but
it did seem like that it didn't seem
like he just like raged out and like
[ __ ] killed everybody cuz I hate you
all or anything like there was another
guy that did that here back in the yes
he had a teenage daughter and a son
everything and he they came up and
school he killed him he had already
killed the mom and he hid everything and
then started a whole new life
they eventually caught him yeah he said
well I just couldn't you know I couldn't
support him they couldn't do my couldn't
do my duty as a father and a husband
anymore so I I it's like don't you wish
it would have been nice and if your wife
the option if she had wanted to like you
know what I mean they were seems a
little always a conscious centered it's
always a kind of situation where the
dude is like real [ __ ] uptight and
really stuck in his ways and he's real
traditionalist it's almost like
something would happen like in Japan
yeah you know it's almost kind of ritual
and that's so bizarre because they feel
like they failed they have to save them
the dishonor right of being poor
yeah that's could I get it that's [ __ ]
up yeah but I get it right like I'm not
saying it's good I think really what a
lot of it is is that they don't want to
look like a failure in front of the
family
yeah that's so so he kills the family -
yeah they don't know of his failure
that's control freak there yeah yeah so
yeah I don't get the family get her look
man I lost my job we can't pay for this
[ __ ] we all have to go to work get
[ __ ] come up with the bills no
matinees like I'm gonna be the sole
breadwinner that that's yes that's
that's what it is I mean that is some
misguided [ __ ] right there
that's what they call toxic masculinity
it well it is that is an aspect of it
because you're essentially you're taking
you know your family's choice away yeah
it's like why don't you give them the
option maybe your wife would have got a
job maybe yes I'll tell you why the only
kind of dude that does that is damn
borderline [ __ ] autistic or something
you know thought about this I mean ice
no normal dude doesn't do that yeah yeah
Tammy says I can live with the
embarrassment of being for me too yeah
yeah I have it's just it's just that you
know it hasn't happened many times it's
like a very very epic type yeah
mental illness yeah something like that
that would make somebody do that yeah
so I'm not sure if that does not do with
upbringing yeah you don't see it as much
as you used to
I'm not sure yeah it's like I'm not sure
if that was the situation in this case
but it definitely does sound like that
um and like I said they're pretty sure
that that's what happened I mean because
they never found his body and I think
they even had some like CCTV footage of
somebody that looked like him like
leaving somewhere being someplace but
that was like the last time they ever
saw him so I'm assuming that he just
killed all of them and buried them under
the terrace and I'm assuming that he
sent the letters to the family so that
was a story I agree the third one three
years
then the fourth one was called a no ride
home this was a really sad one this was
about a guy named Alonzo Brooks and he
ended up going to this party with
friends of his and it was like in a
neighboring town it was somewhere like
in [ __ ] Kansas or something like that
and um he didn't really know anybody at
the party it was a kind of this rural
area and um you know some wires got
crossed somewhere uh where this friend
thought that he was getting a ride home
with the other friend and that friend
thought he got a ride home with the
other friend I think it was like three
guys he was there with or whatever and
he ended up not coming home and he was
missing for quite a while and this was
messed up too like the cops went out
there looking for his body because they
have presumed at this point because you
know his friends went back to the house
the next day and no one was there but
they found like his shoes and his hat
like just kind of like toys know someone
had like tossed him out of a car or
something and like they looked around
and didn't find anything the cops start
looking they didn't find anything and
then finally like a month or two later
the cops told the family that they could
go look and they found his body like
immediately they said it was within
half-an-hour like they just it was
really close to the house yeah and they
just found him like in this ditch or
whatever like he like he was dead yeah
they're not really sure what happened
there's a bunch of theories about what
happened I think he got into a fight
that hearted they killed him it did seem
like I mean and that's the thing that
they're kind of investigating and they
hated the police are
raining under the assumption that maybe
this might have been a hate crime
because he was the only black guy at the
party and some of the other people at
the party said that there were some like
racial slurs being around and white
dudes brought him there and it said yeah
there were friends of his and it was
like a different town and he didn't know
we ignoring some of them dudes and they
were [ __ ] with him but what I don't
understand is that they left him there
he said I guess he said he wanted to
stay they went with him there was an
hour away I'm gonna left him in there I
think well I think what happened cuz
they had his friends on there and they
were like super you know busted up about
it obviously because they thought well
the one guy thought that the other
friend was giving him a ride home and
that guy thought that guy was going
there so like I said they just
accidentally like left in there and it
was like an hour away from their house
um so went so they like went home like
thinking that the other person had
driven him home so they were like really
alarmed like when he wasn't at home the
next day so yeah I think what might have
ended up happening there I was kind of
curious about why the cops supposedly
like searched around this house
everything like that and didn't find the
body until the family went there because
his brother came on and said look we you
know the cops have been out there for
two months they said they did six
searches I think of the area and didn't
find it it's like we were there for half
an hour and found two yeah I found him
right away and he was just late with a
barrier I really thought I was laying
there so people thought that maybe he
was he was put out there after the cops
ended the search bobbles up I believe
it's more a case of like the cops didn't
search strangely because like like I
said the body wasn't buried they showed
a photo I don't think the cops thought
he was there and I don't think they
thought I just did
maybe I don't think they were just did a
half-assed search yeah that's definitely
what I think I don't think the body was
dumped there later because that seems
like it would just be too much trouble
um I definitely think that it was just
cuz the cops didn't really give a [ __ ]
or they didn't really look all that well
so yeah so there was that whole thing
totally they thought he was dead maybe
not maybe the yet they probably thought
he just took off yeah because you know
oh he's a 23 year old guy he probably
just like wandered off and got mad cuz
that's what they always say yeah which
you know I guess I can understand that
because yes it does happen but I don't
know like all it's his family we're like
really upset and they were like telling
the cops look he wouldn't do that it's
like you know so the fifth episode which
was
favorite one got you UFO episode I
thought that was episode 6 now that you
know there was one after that yes I
thought I thought was the best one this
one was fun actually yeah it was a weird
[ __ ] case yeah it's about all these
suck and misfits out it was in New York
or Massachusetts that's right
well he's misfits and different ages are
all kids and they all [ __ ] see a damn
UFO someone were teenagers and [ __ ] and
they all they don't know each other
until they get into the UFO and they see
each other in the UFO and then they
don't remember what happened but then
later on when they were going back to
school over time because there's a small
town they'd run into each other and they
were all you were in the UFO yeah
and it's a pretty cool [ __ ] story
it's just weird happened in 1969 yeah
and um a lot of weird stuff happened in
the case yeah there's not like a one of
the things that they were talking about
on there was that there wasn't like any
physical evidence of it it was just like
these people that had seen it and I
think we talked about a little bit on
the show last night where we were
talking about there was some abduction
[ __ ] going on too although none of the
people that said that they had been
abducted they didn't really like come up
with any they didn't come up with a
crazy story about like seeing aliens or
he couldn't remember much about they
said they didn't really remember they
said they just kind of woke up like in a
room like saw other people there like
other kids or whatever and then they
lost like three hours of time or like
you know woke up and they were like a
mile away from where they had been or
something like that and I think we
mentioned before like the the mom and
the grandma like switching places like
in the car like three hours in one part
of these two kind of teenage girls in
her late teens we're driving they were
driving down the road and they saw a
light and up in the horizon they thought
it was an accident a bunch of cop cars
because it was a big bright light
nervous my colored lights there but when
they pulled up when she got up to it it
was so bright she couldn't see it it was
just this huge bright object and they
got out and looked at it and she said it
was just this big [ __ ] disc and then
it took off I don't think it abducted
her did it I don't think so no yeah cuz
the ones that got abducted I think we're
kids yeah like that so a lot of people
saw it
different locations all in that same
time period and they were talking about
it on the radio but they didn't save any
of the tapes from from the time yeah cuz
like I said that wasn't something that
and that they did some people that were
in the police associated with the police
back in those days remembered when it
happened but they didn't believe it yeah
so they didn't record it yeah I think
maybe that happened I think they thought
people were like [ __ ] ever like
playing a prank ER but a lot of people
evidently saw it in the town yeah some
people claimed that they were in in the
[ __ ] ship that mostly little kids
that they were in the ship and saw each
other there yeah and they didn't know
who they were they didn't recognize each
other until later yeah which is pretty
weird
it's each other at school yeah the ship
you were in the show but and one girl
remembered she's just saw the other kids
there and then they would just wink out
there's leave yeah and then another one
would leave so the alien then also but
then she woke up and she she woke up she
was on a field or something near yes
like I said something like would woke up
like it's a significant distance away
from where they remember last remembered
they had been I thought it was an
interesting story it was yeah I don't
know how much of it is true
but um it was a good story and it made a
good episode yeah anyway it was like
kind of creepy and kind of fun but other
than that that's what's out now and
supposedly there's six five or six moral
there's no there was one more episode
after the UFO one well there was yeah
remember it was the one about it's
called missing witness and it was the
one about Lina Chapin and she grew up in
like that horrible family with like her
crazy my yeah and the mother kept going
like from man to man yeah we're
suspecting allegedly um that the mom
killed the stepdad
yeah and this eldest daughter knew about
it and helps dispose of the body she was
just a little kid or she was 12 or 13 or
something like that and she was like
scared of her mom and then later the
daughter Lina disappeared and the rest
of the family are suspecting that their
mom killed the daughter as well and also
killed the stepdad whose name was Gary
man that storm yeah holy crap jeez but
yeah so that was like a messed up case
I'm like I'm watching that like and all
the twists and turns of this family I'm
like holy crap I really like some
[ __ ]
it's functional [ __ ] it's like it must
be really I just could not imagine being
a little kid and allegedly watching your
mom shoot your stepdad like in the face
or whatever she did I think she shot him
like in the stomach or whatever and then
like having to help your mom like clean
up the thing and then like all the other
sisters like and then this is the later
sister like disappears and they're like
the bomb killed her to you maybe
allegedly kinda reminded me of that
other case that has [ __ ] up but that
crazy-ass [ __ ] that she had those three
daughters remember remember that and
they found she killed one of them to
help the other to put her in a cardboard
box to set her on fire oh [ __ ] I
remember that yeah was that it was this
back in the 80s and then they made she
was making the daughters go to the
[ __ ] truck stops and [ __ ] pimp
themselves out Yanks yeah I was [ __ ]
bad some people should not have gender
yeah well they didn't know what it
happened you know the first time the
cops knew anything about it they just
found it burned up girl's body yeah in
in a cardboard box it didn't destroy
area that but you know they never ID'd
her later on this girl woman can't young
woman came forward and said I'll tell
you who did that my mom did that it's
told the whole story and but I think I
think the mom died that's terrifying
I think she was either died or got sent
to an institution assumption [ __ ]
psycho yeah obviously never too soon as
she was jealous that the daughters were
thin and thin or shapely so she would
force-feed them a whole bunch of [ __ ]
tears go ahead Crisco and [ __ ] what
do you call it
[ __ ] macaroni and cheese and [ __ ] you
guys remember that she's supposed to be
kind of like [ __ ] one of the most
evil women woman of all times actually
she was on a [ __ ] series called
history's most evil I think our most
evil I remember that there I mean that
one it was on there she's one I'd
[ __ ] [ __ ] up pretty bad five I met
her I mean that's a [ __ ] her up pretty
bad that's terrible yeah she's evil god
damn
and the reason why she killed the duck
that daughter the older daughters cuz
she wanted to leave home and she had
already shocked that daughter with a 25
[ __ ] caliber pistol years before and
she said you're not going anywhere until
I get that bullet out of you she even
wants a [ __ ] book and she cut that
bullet out of her with a [ __ ] kitchen
knife and took it out she had it up
dying I think of uh I think she died of
some kind of infection like set the same
here yeah after that and it's like and
then they dumped her body out there and
she used the other daughters to dump the
body [ __ ] yeah and she had yeah no I
gotta look that [ __ ] up yes I don't
remember her name that's terrible I mean
I'm sure I can I can google through that
[ __ ] um Tammy asked if I said his recent
nor oh yeah that sounds familiar
that sounds familiar let me good that
might be the name yeah
I've heard that name before I just
didn't remember the details of the case
it was more about it I think she killed
another one of the daughters chained it
up chained that daughter up and [ __ ] his
starved her to death or something man
that's kind of like that [ __ ] case
that uh that uh the girl next door was
based on like that that woman that like
kept those girls in the [ __ ] basement
and like let the neighborhood boys rape
her and stuff yeah you return about that
yeah that's most that happened in the
50s I think yeah there's something like
that just happened a few weeks back
member that they found some kid nude
[ __ ] some kid some guy he's been
thinking about twelve thirteen fourteen
but they said he is so bad they starved
you look like a child yeah I found him
running around I think no clothes on her
damn [ __ ] chain around his neck and
he led him back to the house where he
came from and they had a big old fat
woman and a fat dude living in there
fully starving children they have
chained up some had died from starvation
and they were that's right I was there
two of them buried out in our backyard
and then they wouldn't say any more
about it
evidently they had legal custody of
those kids but they weren't theirs I
don't know if they were foster children
or yeah maybe they were fostering and
they didn't have any oversight yeah it's
weird [ __ ] cuz foster kids they're
supposed to like come and [ __ ] check
on him every yeah but I was checking on
Oh Tammy asked me if I had finished
watching dark I haven't um I was just
like I said I was trying to you know
watch the
one and two again before I watch season
3 so I'm still like only on season 1
still but uh cuz like I said it's so
it's such a complicated show and it's
like I really couldn't remember like
everything that happened in it and I
didn't want to go into like season 3 but
I'll try to do it like this week and
then maybe do like a review of it so
what else do we have - that's it I'm
just about I'm just thinking about
matters good thing I don't get I can't
get my hands on those people cuz it it
because the way the way the apocalypse
is going man this is gonna be like a
carnival-like atmosphere when you catch
people like that you know these two used
to catch serial killers back the 1300s
they'd have a whole carnival around
torturing that dude to death yeah yeah
that's what its gonna get to eventually
it's gonna go back to that they're gonna
grease you up and put you in the [ __ ]
and think how much brass bowl think of
how much money you can make if you know
if you were like the cops or some kind
of authorities look we got them we've
tried I'm found guilty we have a big old
carnival thing and you can sell tickets
to that my grandma used to always say
whenever they caught something that like
a serial killer or somebody did
something really really horrible and
they got like convicted she would always
say they should time to tree and just
let everybody come by and slice off a
piece yeah my grandma yeah would
surprise me if history starts repeating
itself again goes back to like the Dark
Ages America falls apart becomes like
the Dark Ages again where's the high
tech though high tech Darth Vader cases
yeah I've got electricity computers and
[ __ ] carnivals of [ __ ] carnage and
[ __ ] carnival of carnival of carnage
where you where they [ __ ] take these
bad [ __ ] and do some break them
on the wheel or something like they did
back in the old back in the back in the
old days and then you buy tickets to it
they make [ __ ] millions of dollars
many record itself let's see these jib
CDs what century yeah yeah yeah forgot
your grandpa
start talking about [ __ ] a track
track or Betamax yeah where's my Betamax
we had a Betamax for a little while
we had a Betamax for a little while and
then we got a VHS after we realized we
had both for a while and then like after
we realized that the car oh okay I was
gonna say that's got to be something
who is Betamax was a [ __ ] robot
transform is a big [ __ ] maximum beta
Betamax was the precursor to VHS yeah
now if you say what's VHS then I can't
help you it's like I know I'm old but
Betamax was actually better than VHS the
quality is better quality but it just
the tapes were like more they were like
shorter but wider yeah you know what I
mean it was a better image and
everything it was they made so many VHS
players so quickly and it just flooded
the market a lot of people around that
same time lucky we don't know but they
had laserdisc yeah it was like DVD but
it was the size of a record our record
album and they had [ __ ] superior
superior quality [ __ ] it was almost
HD it was good but it just it was so
[ __ ] expensive yeah one of those
laser discs was almost a hundred bucks I
worked in a record store in 1993 and we
had like a little section of laser discs
and I think the whole time I worked
there I never saw a single person looks
expensive I mean they didn't have a huge
you know number of titles that you could
pick from and yeah they were very
expensive I didn't know anybody who had
laser discs and know anybody had latex
players I don't even think I've ever
watched a movie on laserdisc just just
priced itself out of the market I don't
it didn't have to be that expensive did
it I don't think it did No
but like I said you know when when VHS
first came out and when they first
started releasing like because for a
time when VHS came out it was mostly
just tape and [ __ ] like off of TV get a
movie you didn't get a movie so like
later when they started like releasing
commercial movies like on VHS some of
them were like hugely expensive I
remember like in the late 80s or early
90s whenever Rocky Horror Picture Show
came out on VHS it was $99 yes which I
know [ __ ] I remember the videotape
yeah yeah Star Wars was like 150 bucks
yeah it was like a ridiculous amount I
remember going to [ __ ] media play and
I wanted to buy it I was like well okay
I don't have a [ __ ] thought that she
was precious man they thought that [ __ ]
was precious they watch you having a
movie they were threatened by that I
feel like it went it went from like home
taping and then porn obviously cuz
Warren was like an early adopter but
rapport is like an early adopter of like
pretty much every technology every media
technology and then finally like you
know they they got into the thing of
making commercials we rent those [ __ ]
tapes from Blockbuster men and we
thought these things were worth the [ __ ]
they were expensive yeah we treated them
like they're expensive - yeah little do
we know you could just [ __ ] him record
that [ __ ] for a dollar well yeah just a
dollar and like I said it later on you
know my dad got one of those VHS that
had like the two decks yeah and we would
happy yes he could copy except for the
ones that had macrovision but you could
get you could get workarounds for that
and then a VHS player was like nearly
$1000 yeah and then like it just seemed
like one day they were only like 200
yeah and then like a few years later
they were like 40 bucks yeah like what I
know and then it's like you know and
even though even our broke asses lay
eventually we had one in like each room
you know yeah like everybody had their
own I remember it got to the point to
where you know as VHS was dying and
being replaced with licken DVD a VHS
favorites like 20 bucks they couldn't
give away you see them down the [ __ ]
dollar store well now people now if
anybody even having them anymore they
break and people throw them away it's
just like even like [ __ ] you know bit
HD TVs and stuff like that and they're
so cheap now that yeah and a DDG about
DVD players hundreds of dollars and
that's that's now like [ __ ] 18 bucks
20 bucks to worthless now yeah
worthless well changes no more you know
the technology becomes ubiquitous like
the cheaper it becomes yeah alright so I
guess yeah it's gonna it's gonna storm
probably yeah I don't know if the towers
gonna go out or whatever and I gotta
finish doing the laundry so yeah I will
probably watch some more of dark maybe
tonight and oh I also have to watch the
next movie that we're doing a
retrospective on which I'm not going to
spoil it but I'm sure everyone will be
very excited about I'm very excited
about doing it it's been on my list for
a long time but yeah so we will probably
do another live stream tomorrow movie
reviews I track something like that
probably about 2 or 3 o'clock in the
afternoon depending on what else we're
doing so we'll talk to you guys again
tomorrow thanks for everybody for come
by